so one of the fastest-growing
coronavirus hotspots is Florida Florida
of course led by the completely
incompetent Smurf Republican Governor
Ron de santis now De Santis failed to
even close beaches in Florida until
pretty recently he's been way behind on
everything even more behind than Trump
if you can imagine that and DeSantis is
continued failure has really been
putting Floridians including the largely
elderly population in Florida at really
big existential life-and-death risk and
so finally yesterday Ron de santis
issued a 30-day stay at home order that
starts tomorrow Friday Florida has now
reached about 8,000 cases and may likely
be beyond that by the time you listen to
today's show and Florida's one of those
places that Donald Trump and others for
a long time have continued to say you
know Florida doesn't really have that
many cases they don't necessarily have
to do that much the governor can decide
what to do and what we're hopefully by
now realizing and many of us knew it
from the beginning because health
experts have been saying it is the folly
of not understanding how a virus spreads
we call things going viral for a reason
and now that has put Florida at nearly
8,000 cases at what is still a
relatively early stage of the pandemic
and remember the effects of stay at home
orders often take two full weeks to be
seen that stay at home order starts
tomorrow we could see a continued climb
a drastic climb in Florida in both cases
and eventually deaths until the end of
April or the second half of April I
think better said this is what we mean
by going viral you initially don't have
a lot of cases and then you do consider
a state with just two hundred cases we
hear you know from from Trump and
sometimes from dr. Burks you know there
are places with only 200 cases they
don't necessarily need to do all the
same stuff as other places imagine just
20% case case growth now some places are
seeing 30 or 35 percent case growth per
day but imagine 200 cases growing 20% a
day very quickly in just 10 days you go
from 200 cases to a thousand
cases if at that point you say hey you
know what let's now put in a
stay-at-home order you now are trying to
mitigate the spread of a thousand cases
rather than 200 and by two weeks you
could be you know at 20,000 who even
knows this is how it spreads so DeSantis
now finally issuing a stay at home order
starts tomorrow
but of course it'll take two weeks for
that to start really doing anything
it'll be the second half of April and
Florida very well could have instead of
8,000 cases they could have 20,000 they
could have 30,000 cases and this all
happened without a stay at home order
which is now being done in a panicked
way so the I don't I mean at this point
it's like if you still don't have a stay
at home order what are you waiting for
but we should feel like we are
overreacting
when some states early Washington to
some degree California to some degree
Massachusetts when these states said
stay at home no you know only takeout or
delivery it felt to some like an
overreaction you need an overreaction if
you are playing policies take 10 to 14
days to have an impact if you are
reacting to the numbers you have you are
already two weeks behind Florida has 22
million residents this is more people
than many countries have Chile has fewer
people than Florida the Netherlands has
fewer people than Florida Cambodia
Belgium Florida has a larger population
than many many countries they've already
got over 8,000 cases roughly 8,000 cases
it can get very ugly and Florida's
demographics are not good in the sense
of who is at risk Florida has the fifth
oldest median population in the country
only Maine Vermont New Hampshire and
West Virginia have an older population
than Florida we have to watch Florida it
could get very ugly and Florida
residents have not been well served by
Republican governor Ron de santis
horrible horrible response and many
Republican governors have done okay one
of the best responses was Ohio
Republican Governor Mike DeWine a pretty
good response was Massachusetts
Republican governor
Baker so we're going to continue
following it and we we are hoping that
Florida will start mitigating soon
because otherwise the numbers are going
to be absolutely tragic there's a
YouTube channel we're partnering with
that I would love for you to check out
it's a channel called up flip you can
get there by clicking the link below
make sure you subscribe when you're
there every week up flip uploads a new
video where you get an exclusive
behind-the-scenes look at a different
small business everything from real
estate firms coffee shops auto repair
shops each business owner shares a ton
of really interesting insight about how
they built their business what it's like
day-to-day how they got to where they
are fascinating to learn about other
people's business strategies how they
found success it's a great channel for
anyone thinking of starting a business
already running one or just people
interested in how different business
work perfect for people who like TV
shows like shark tank and that type of
thing check it out at david pakman.com
slash up flip the link is underneath the
video they are friends of the david
pakman show make sure to subscribe when
you're there click that Bell icon to be
notified when they upload new videos